The "Anchorman" movies are already
hilarious — but the bloopers amp the
funny up to 11. From improvised condom names to
Ron's sexual fascination with Mrs. Butterworth,
these laugh-out-loud outtakes prove that sometimes
the funniest moments don't make the final cut.
Diving into a character and delivering hours upon
hours of ad libbing is a near-impossible feat for
many actors. However, Will Ferrell naturally
adopted the overly arrogant characteristics
of news anchor Ron Burgundy from the
moment he put on the three-piece suit.
"Hey, everyone! Come see how good I look."
One of the best examples of Ferrell's
aptitude for the character occurs
when he is left to his own devices.
Before the evening news camera roles,
Burgundy often warms up his vocal cords with
original tongue twisters or obnoxious screaming.
"Ho ho! Ho ho ho! Hooooooo!
Hooo-hoooo! Ho-hooooo!"
However,the deleted scenes showcase how
one of these lines was too silly,
even for Ferrell. While repeating a line about
the human torch being denied a bank loan,
Ferrell and the behind-the-scenes
crew were doubled over in laughter.
Ferrell and the rest of the onscreen
performers deserve most of the
credit for making the "Anchorman" movies
monumental comedic achievements. However,
director Adam McKay is just as responsible
for a significant portion of the hilarity.
McKay co-wrote the script for both
"Anchorman" movies with Ferrell,
and his humor is peppered throughout the stories.
However, the director had just as much influence
on the improvisational humor as some of the stars.
Throughout many of the bloopers and outtakes,
McKay can be heard hollering lines and jokes from
behind the camera. The best example of McKay's
cleverness comes in an "Anchorman 2" scene.
In the scene, Ferrell is discussing breast
implants with co-star Paul Rudd, and cracks that
they now use taco meat as the filler. But when
McKay suggests "Nickels" from off-screen,
both Rudd and Ferrell have a quick laugh.
Of course, even an anchorman of Ron Burgundy's
caliber wouldn't be anywhere without
a superstar news team. Thankfully,
the movie did an outstanding job of filling
out the crew behind the Channel 4 News. The
diverse group of funnymen included David
Koechner, Paul Rudd, and Steve Carell.
While fans got to know the entire Channel 4
News team well over the course of two films,
many deleted scenes helped audiences
learn even more about them. Much of
the content deleted from the original
"Anchorman" film was collected into
the direct-to-video counterpart film
"Wake Up, Ron Burgundy: The Lost Movie."
However, the blooper reel for the first
"Anchorman" showcases a collection of
unused taglines by the four seasoned stars
of San Diego's favorite news. Filmed in
the same tone as a short TV commercial,
the Channel 4 News crew delivers a quick
line that perfectly encapsulates their
characters. Burgundy fittingly says:
"Nothing like a good strong lady and a tasty BLT."
Meanwhile, Carell's not-so-bright weatherman
character Brick nails it on the head saying,
"When there is weather to
report, I report the weather."
While the first "Anchorman's" assortment of
comedians helped make the movie a success,
"Anchorman 2" brought in so many well-known
actors that the film struggled to fit them
all in. Cleverly, the sequel doubled down on
a famous scene from the first movie where the
Channel 4 News team got into a tussle with a
rival group of anchors. However, in "Anchorman
2," the fight got much bigger, involving news
teams from all over the world. Furthermore,
each group features some of the biggest names in
Hollywood, including Will Smith and Jim Carrey.
With so many funny people in one place, shooting
the fight scene was understandably a rambunctious
occasion. And the "Anchorman 2" bloopers do
not disappoint in showing off the chaos. One
outtake shows how difficult it was for Carrey
to remember his Canadian news anchor name.
"Without… what the hell's my name?"
The entire event must have been too
much for everyone because even comedy
veteran Will Smith wound up crying
— probably from laughing so hard.
Filming a movie as hilarious as "Anchorman"
without laughing sounds like an insurmountable
job. So it's no wonder that the majority of
the outtakes and bloopers on this list feature
someone bursting into laughter. However,
a few scenes went off the rails without
giggling — most notably, a deep conversation Ron
Burgundy had with his beloved pet dog Baxter.
In the scene from the first movie,
Ferrell's character is greeted by his
loyal canine after returning home from
work. When Burgundy tells Baxter about his
love life in an extended outtake, he says:
"I think it was Aristotle who said: Come
children. Let me tell you a tale about
ships and whales."
In an unforgettable scene
from the first "Anchorman," Brian Fantana
shares his secret to success with women,
revealing his off-brand cologne "Sex Panther."
So, obviously, when it came to making a sequel
to "Anchorman," the writers wanted to develop a
similar scene in hopes of recreating the magic.
For "Anchorman 2," Fantana's cupboard gets much
larger than holding one bottle of cologne. Rather,
he has an entire shrine of condoms and
lubricants that he shares with the rest
of the Channel 4 News team. The scene is a
hysterical moment during the finalized film,
but the bloopers take it up another
notch. Analyzing different condoms,
the actors improvise an assortment of
lines around their individual purposes.
As Veronica Corningstone, Christina Applegate
plays the even-tempered professional thrown
into the clown show known as Channel 4
News. Burgundy and crew grow to resent
the anchorwoman stepping into a role
beside them, so they hatch a plan to
ruin her career. This is showcased when the
news team attempts to throw her off by making
faces and gestures while she's live on air —
but Corningstone remains completely unfazed.
"I'm Veronica Corningstone, and
thanks for stopping by San Diego."
However, as easy as Applegate's
character made it look in the movie,
the actress had a much harder time keeping a
straight face. One blooper depicts Applegate
giggling as Paul Rudd and David Koechner
taunt her while she reads her news report.
As weatherman Brick Tamland,
Steve Carell quickly became a
fan favorite and delivered some of the most
quotable lines in the "Anchorman" movies.
"I love lamp."
Rudd admitted in an interview with GQ that one
scene with Carell made him "laugh the hardest."
The moment in question involved Carell's
character eating a wrap for lunch. However,
the meal consisted of a used coffee filter wrapped
around a cigarette butt and loose change.
Aside from Ferrell, the next biggest name on
screen in "Anchorman" was Paul Rudd. In an
interview with GQ, Rudd pointed to one particular
scene when he struggled to hold it together. It
takes place after the Channel 4 News team
gets into a street fight with a rival crew
from another news channel. Licking their wounds in
Ron Burgundy's office, Ferrell delivers the line,
"I'm proud of you fellas. You
all kept your head on a swivel.
And that's what you got to do when you
find yourself in a vicious cockfight."
The improvised bit proved too
much for the veteran Rudd,
as he remembers breaking character and laughing.
"That's not in the script or anything
and I was like, 'Took me by surprise.'"
Meanwhile, the blooper reel reveals
that Ferrell also couldn't help
but laugh at his own impromptu joke.
David Koechner's performance as Champ Kind
rounded out the fantastic four of Channel 4, as he
uttered some of the crew's most obscene comments.
"I'm all about having fun. You
know, get a couple cocktails in me.
Start a fire in someone's kitchen."
Surely, Koechner enjoyed playing the
role, as Champ resembles other characters
he has played. However, when it came to
returning to do the "Anchorman" sequel,
the actor may have gotten a little
too excited. In a scene where Champ
Kind embraces his old friend Ron Burgundy,
the hug gets awkward and a tad aggressive.
The moment is even funnier in the outtakes, as
Koechner takes the uncomfortable moment further.
Over the course of two movies, there is enough
"Anchorman" to leave everyone's sides hurting
from laughter. However, Rudd found one scene
so funny that he couldn't even get through it.
During an interview with The Ringer, he mentions
the scene from the first film where Ferrell says,
"Milk was a bad choice," which was nearly
ruined by laughter. But it was a joke from
Ferrell in the sequel that really took the
cake for Rudd. During the scene in question,
Burgundy is so depressed from
losing everything that he remarks:
"The other day I pleasured myself
to the image of Mrs. Buttersworth."
Thankfully, this hilarious moment
also made it into the blooper reels.
The hilarity continued in the "Anchorman 2"
scene in which the Channel 4 News team arrived
at Burgundy's house to cheer him up. Wrapped in a
blanket and suffering from depression, Ferrell's
character is completely over-the-top with his
self-depreciation, much to the frustration of his
friends. However, for the actors, it was easily
one of the most entertaining days of filming.
During one outtake from the scene, Burgundy
compares his suffering to that of the Elephant
Man. He then does an impression of the
Elephant Man, which instantly breaks Rudd.
Ferrell has spent his entire career surrounded
by some of Hollywood's funniest people. The
actor famously makes everybody around him
break character while he improvises and
takes things to unexpected levels. It
is only fair that once in a blue moon,
the comedic dynamo loses control and ruins
a scene by laughing. However, in "Anchorman
2," Ferrell is bested by an actor that you would
least suspect to make him laugh, Harrison Ford.
In the movie, Ford plays a superstar anchorman
who does not have a soft spot for Burgundy. During
one of the film's few serious moments,
when Ford's character talks about being
responsible for the death of a window washer,
Ferrell can't help but burst into laughter.
One of the funniest gags from "Anchorman 2,"
involved Champ Kind leaving the news business
behind and opening a fried chicken
restaurant. The movie explains how
Kind faked an accident at work and used the
settlement money to open his joint. However,
in an effort to save money, Koechner's character
explains that he uses bats instead of poultry.
Amusingly, Koechner was on top of
using his character's situation
and improvised many jokes about
using other possible meats. One
outtake finds Ferrell cracking up
after Koechner delivers this line:
"I figure after it's been in a
deep fryer, it's no longer human."
Among the best parts of watching the
"Anchorman" movies is catching the
never-ending assortment of celebrity cameos.
However, two cameos proved perfectly fitting
considering Ferrell and McKay shared a
long history of collaborating with them
on "Saturday Night Live." Tina Fey and Amy
Poehler seamlessly entered their way into
the news team royal rumble in "Anchorman
2" representing an all-female news crew.
Poehler and Fey together in front of a camera
equals comedy magic. There are multiple bloopers
and outtakes showcasing the non-stop giggling and
joking the two women brought to the set. Fey and
Poehler also improvised many hilarious lines
during their short appearance, including this gem:
"I'll ride your mustache all the way to hell."
In a hilarious outtake from"Anchorman 2," Ferrell
is guilty of blurting out the wrong cast member's
name when sharing a scene with Koechner. Ferrell
incidentally calls Koechner "Brick," which happens
to be the first name of Steve Carell's character.
Where most actors would take the simple mistake
in stride, Koechner hilariously punishes
Ferrell by telling him, "Brick's dead!"
The "Anchorman" movies are so funny that even
when the actors are keeping to the script,
they still can't help but laugh. For instance,
in "Anchorman 2," Rudd's character shares an
upcoming expose about "the powers and
mysteries of the human vagina," which
proves to be too much for Ferrell in an
outtake. Amusingly, Rudd does not let up,
calling it an "explosive piece," which
almost puts Ferrell on the floor.
In "Anchorman 2", Steve Carell played the Channel
4 weatherman with as much ridiculousness as he
did the first time around. Between delivering
a eulogy at his own funeral to getting married
to the love of his life, Brick also had a
far more significant role in the sequel.
"Brick was a great man and I miss him so much.
And I will not rest until I find his killer."
However, that did not mean that he was not
up to his old gags. Sure, Carell's character
doesn't eat another coffee filter, but the
bloopers show he had just as many struggles
chowing down food. For instance, one outtake
shows him spitting beer all over himself.
A significant challenge that many movie
productions face when filming outside of a
studio, is excessive noise — particularly,
airplanes and helicopters. Thankfully,
when a movie like "Anchorman" is
fully loaded with comedic talent,
even an unforeseen obstruction
can become a side-splitting joke.
Hilariously, when a loud helicopter ruined
a scene for "Anchorman," Ferrell joked that
his personal transport had arrived. Quipping
that he has a helicopter to travel him around
San Diego is an ongoing joke for Burgundy. The
first time audiences met the local anchorman at
the beginning of the first film in 2004, he
stepped out of a "Channel 4 News" chopper.
In an additional scene involving Champ
Kind's unorthodox fried chicken restaurant,
David Koechner gets beaten by his own joke
when Rudd delivers a line that completely
catches him off guard. In the outtake,
Koechner's character asks his friend
to "Name a meat," to which Fantana replies,
"chicken." Out of all the potential answers,
Koechner was obviously not expecting that
one, and instantaneously burst into laughter.
One of the most awkward parts about being an
actor or actress must be sharing extremely
intimate scenes with a co-star. So,
we imagine it was almost impossible
for Christina Applegate to keep a straight face
during her "Anchorman" bed scene with Ferrell.
It's particularly hard to forget the part of
the scene in which Burgundy and Applegate's
Veronica Corningstone make out. After all,
aggressive biting of lips and far too much
tongue transformed a standard kissing session
into comedy gold for audiences. Of course,
Ferrell's goofball antics had Applegate cracking
up, as seen in the film's blooper reel.
Not many performers can match Carell's level
of hilarity — seven seasons
on "The Office" proved that.
"It's Michael Scott."
However, when seeking someone to
play opposite Carell for "Anchorman
2," McKay knocked it out of the park
by hiring "Saturday Night Live" alum
Kristen Wiig. Wiig and Carell delivered
an onscreen connection that was perfect,
and better described as pure awkwardness.
What makes their off-beat romance even more
entertaining is the fact that much of their time
on-screen together was completely improvised.
The bloopers released for "Anchorman
2" are packed to the brim with outtakes
featuring Carell and Wiig making each other
laugh. That said, one scene between the two
goes completely off the rails when Carell
tells Wiig that his favorite food is pee.
Ron Burgundy's turnaround in "Anchorman 2" occurs
when he realizes that he wants to deliver America
the news that they want to hear — like why the
USA is the greatest place on Earth. Before that,
however, Burgundy was in serious trouble
of finding his voice while in the national
spotlight. The scene between Ferrell and
Dylan Baker, who plays Burgundy's boss,
is vital to pushing the movie forward — and
resulted in one of the movie's greatest bloopers.
In the scene, Baker's character gets mad
at Burgundy's ideas and finally says,
"That's not news!" Ferrell is supposed to
respond with a line about grabbing popcorn
and watching the end of the world, but breaks
character before he can even get the words out.
There is another "Anchorman" star that does
not get enough credit: Burgundy's loyal pet
pup Baxter. Surprisingly, this furry actor
was almost the reason the beloved comedy film
received a more mature rating than PG-13.
Baxter appears in much of the first film,
including one particularly memorable
scene where he's kicked off a bridge
by Jack Black. The dog plays a pivotal
role in the plot and in Burgundy's heart.
"You know how to cut to the core of me, Baxter."
However, McKay revealed in the
director's commentary that Baxter
nearly earned "Anchorman" an R rating. The
pup had a habit of revealing its genitalia,
and his parts can be seen throughout the film.
Apparently, the Motion Picture Association of
America abides by a strict rule stating that a
movie will get an instant R for more than five
seconds of close-up images of male genitalia —
and that includes animals! So McKay was forced
to edit out several shots of the cute,
fluffy pup and his overly apparent parts.